pour Jurassic World, il était important pour
moi d'impliquer le plus possible de personnes qui ont
rendu Jurassic Park génial dans les
coulisses de ce film. Mon
histoire avec Jurassic Park remonte en fait
au premier, puis j'ai continué à
faire Jurassic Park 3 comme  le
concepteur de production et maintenant je suis ici en train de faire Jurassic
Park car tous sont une grande
réussite, je veux dire qu'ils nous ont mis dans des
endroits et veulent que nous créions des choses que
personne n'a jamais vues revenir ici 21
ans plus tard, c'est remarquable pour le
tournage  à quelques mètres de l'endroit où
nous avons tourné le centre d'accueil pour nous un
quart, Michael Crichton a basé son
personnage d'Alan Grant sur moi,
alors quand Steven cherchait quelqu'un
pour aider à être le conseiller technique, il
m'appelait Colin était principalement intéressé
par moi pour les scènes  avec les Raptors, ils avaient
besoin de beaucoup de comportement de performance
parce qu'il ne voulait pas que les créatures
soient des monstres, il voulait qu'elles soient un
séjour debout honnête juste là,
bien respirer, c'est regarder  ing bon Jason pour
que Jurassic Park devienne vraiment et
vraiment le premier film à mettre un dinosaure
à l'écran qui était réaliste et
crédible, c'était un véritable honneur d'en faire
partie car il continue avec
ce processus dans ce film pour moi, il y a
un  l'esprit de ces gars infusés dans ce
film et donc si vous regardez ce film et que
vous dites que cela ressemble à Jurassic Park pour
moi, j'enverrais quelques-uns des félicitations
qu'ils font